hi welcome to another ColdFusion video a
couple of days ago Elon Musk held a
press conference at the SpaceX
headquarters he revealed a fascinating
project in my view a project to send
citizens to the moon on a torus flyby
it's no secret that Elon houses a fair
share of controversy around him but for
a second let's push aside the celebrity
version of Elon and focus on the
engineering side in this video we'll
take a look at the possible new world of
lunar tourism proposed by the CEO of the
company this lunar mission isn't just
some crazy idea from a company that has
no experience in the space industry
SpaceX is routinely launching satellites
and has already sent multiple tons of
cargo to the International Space Station
via their contract with NASA and next
year the company is going to start
manned missions to the space station
right now I'm ten centimeters per second
lately the nominal truck deploy
[Music]
this isn't to mention the successful
testing of the Falcon Heavy the world's
largest rocket at the moment
it was no easy feat landing those rocket
boosters vertically and keep in mind
what you're seeing is larger than the 15
story building so with that in mind
let's take a look at the proposal for
this latest lunar mission there's going
to be eight carefully selected
passengers traveling on space axes new
bfr spaceship the way these passengers
were selected may be the most
interesting part but we'll get to that
in a little bit we've talked before
about the bfr in previous episodes but
essentially it's a massive spacecraft
suited for long distance travel
it's 118 meters or 387 feet long and is
capable of carrying a hundred people the
interior is custom configured for each
trip with areas dedicated for cargo
emergency air and suppliers living
quarters and possibly zero-gravity
entertainment
the mission will launch from Earth do a
loop around the moon and then possibly
fly a little bit further into space to
see both the moon and Earth from a
distance after this the crew will make
its way back to earth in a vertical
landing procedure the trip is set to
last five days in total the test
scheduled for the VFR and this trip will
be as follows there'll be a half an hour
flight next year and then a high
altitude high velocity flight in 2020
and then the first orbital test will be
in 2021 there'll be plenty of test runs
without passengers but the actual first
manned orbit around the moon will be in
2023 if all goes well the estimated cost
of the PFR is around five to ten billion
dollars now that may sound like a lot of
money but once you consider that the
Apollo missions cost over 100 billion
and that the BFI is reusable is only a
fraction of the cost so how will the
passengers selected in the press
conference musk introduces the first
passenger for the civilian lunar mission
Japanese billionaire Masako Nozawa a
former rock band drummer and the founder
of the Japanese online retailer Zoe's a
town the first customer of VFR
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you everyone oh I cannot speak
English very well so please recent
carefree hizaki
had actually bought an entire be a fast
pace ship his contribution will
partially fund the research and
development of the spacecraft since he
was a child
Hisako has always been an ore of the
moon and he wanted to follow a dream I
think these days many people will look
down on him for being rich but this
situation is much more nuanced yuusaku
is actually being very generous in this
case quote I did not want to have such a
fantastic experience by myself that
would be a little lonely I don't like
being alone so I want to share these
experiences and bring these things to as
many people as possible so that's why I
choose to go to the moon with artists
end quote
so that quote might sound funny on first
impressions but it's actually quite a
nice philosophical idea
the Japanese billionaire wants to invite
eight artists such as musicians of film
directors writers and painters along for
the moon ride free of charge he imagined
that when they fly out to the moon and
look back on the earth in full view they
would be inspired to create incredible
works of art
yosaku imagines that the resulting works
will benefit all of humanity his name
for the new project is called DMA and if
I can say so for myself this man is very
brave to put up his hand and to say I'm
gonna do this to be the first volunteer
for such an ambitious project and
literally risking your life in a very
real sense takes courage in the press
conference Ilan was being realistic
about the risk he stated that he was
fairly certain that the mission and the
development will all go to plan but he
repeatedly stressed the dangers as much
as the numbers work out Ilan can never
be a hundred percent certain that even
the test VFR flights will work and then
of course we do we have reality and
things to not go right in reality
usually there are many setbacks and
issues but there's so many uncertainties
it's not a half percent certain that we
succeed in getting this to flight it's
not even a percent certain like I think
it's put pretty likely but it's not
certain yeah but we're gonna do
everything humanly possible to bring it
to flight as fast as we can and as
safely as we can so in viewing this I
know there's probably a lot of
reductionists out there that would say
that this kind of thing is stupid why go
to space at all
or even for such people as this they can
be benefits and going to space going to
space especially in a reusable and
regular fashion is hard there needs to
be innovation to overcome and solve
problems and challenges what often
results out of this process are spin-off
technologies such as new materials or
novel improvements in power generation
for example the NASA missions brought us
spin-off technologies like aircraft
anti-icing the digital image sensor in
your smartphone or solar powers in their
current form as a nice little cherry on
top
Boeing has thrown their hat in the ring
and they stated that the first crew to
go to Mars will be aboard a Boeing
spacecraft and this was a launch
reaction okay that's what I want to ask
you given the increased competition good
what do you
to say today thank you so much I mean it
like competitions a good thing it's like
races are interesting I say like how
boring that really goes like hardcore
for moon and and Mars missions yeah are
you really great you know I think
that'll be cool amazing to tell base in
the moon
particularly if it was like something
where like the average person if they
saved up could go that would be
incredible
that's like the kind of thing you want
to do so we've seen this before in the
electric car space Tesla changed things
up in the industry after a hundred years
and then suddenly all the established
car brands are talking about electric
cars they don't want to be left behind
increased competition is ultimately a
good thing it means better products in
the end just like Tesla and electric
cars there's now some competition in
space travel
this could be the start of a very real
private space race and that's kind of
amazing just think just ten years ago I
would have never dreamed that I'd see
such things happening so soon soon we
might be walking on the moon again and
it's about time the last time he went to
the moon was December of 1972
these are definitely exciting times and
we'll have to watch this story closely
so what do you guys think let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below anyway so that just about wraps up
the video thanks for watching guys this
has been - go go you have been watching
cold fusion if you've just stumbled
across this channel feel free to
subscribe and feel free to share this
video if you think that you know someone
that will be interested in this thanks
for watching and I'll see you again soon
for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
[Music]